the more comfortable I get as a
performer over years and years and years
of practicing and performing over and
over again for lots of different
audiences the more present I am able to
be in the room so instead of losing
myself in performance I actually find my
exact location in a very visceral way so
I become increasingly aware of everybody
in the audience and what they're doing I
know who is falling asleep I know who is
checking their phone I know who is
picking their nose I know who's wearing
a red sweater in the front row because
when I'm nervous
I can't do that right when you're in
your head and oh I'm performing a no-no
I hope this goes well at it
it's it's very difficult to be
physically present with all those people
because it's too much coming at you but
when I'm in the zone and I'm excited and
I'm tuned in to this performance I'm
able to be very much aware of who's here
which I think is helpful because it
allows me to be performing specifically
for this room the way that I perform for
a classroom of fifth graders is very
different from the way that I perform at
a dive bar or the way that I perform for
a stadium of 3,000 people and it should
be you should feel a difference in my
performance if you're in the audience
for one of those shows so I think when
I'm onstage if I'm having a great show
and I'm really tuned in you can tell
because I'm able to be very much aware
and present with the people in the room
and create a show that is meant for them
I try to look for opportunities to
communicate that I am in the same room
that they're in so if I can make a joke
about something that's happening here or
if I have a reference to what city were
in or if someone's wearing a t-shirt
that I recognize and can associate with
anything like that is a way of
communicating I am in the same space you
are and we're participating in something
together which also allows some part of
an audience's brain to go oh I really
had to be here which is a nice feeling
to have as an audience member so
acknowledging that they've taken the
time to be in this space with you and
you want them to know that you're aware
of that something that I think I will
never get over is the fact that it is a
genuine gift when people are willing to
sit in an audience and give you their
time and attention and breath that's
something that they could have spent
anywhere else but they chose to give it
to you here and it's something that I'm
very cognizant of when I'm on stage and
a big part of what I want to do when I'm
on stage is find a way to acknowledge
those people that have come and are here
in this space and create an environment
that acknowledges that and also rewards
them for that how can we attune
ourselves to what's happening in this
room so that later everyone leaves
feeling like oh I really had to be I
really had to be here for that I'm glad
I was a part of what happened tonight
I had a teacher in college who used to
say that when you're watching a play on
a stage
if somebody spills a glass of water
that's the most important thing that
happened in that scene because that
wasn't fake nothing about water spilling
is fake you see the water and everyone
in the room goes that's water and it
just spilled and that's the only thing
you can focus on because it's the most
authentic piece of what's happening in
the room right now or if someone if
there's an accident and someone gets
hurt that's the only thing you can focus
on because it's the most authentic real
thing that's happening in the room so I
think when people are delivering content
and they're focused only on themselves
their delivery what they've practiced
what they've rehearsed what they've done
to the mirror and they're not aware of
the room oftentimes they're performing
in a vacuum and other people can tell
people in audience are like this isn't
for me this is for themselves this is in
their own brains I think the most
powerful thing people can do is to spill
the glass of water
not literally but to find a moment that
is real to find a moment that is
actually happening here in the room with
the people here to let them know I'm
with you here not in my own vacuum
practicing to the mirror somewhere that
what's happening here is a real moment
and you can create that by acknowledging
something in the room
I referencing something that happened
earlier that you were all witness to
making a reference to an inside joke
that this group of people all share
based on where you work or where you
live or the weather or what's been
happening in the news all of those are
ways of genuinely making something real
here as opposed to hoping that what you
prepared in the past is somehow maybe
relevant now